now I want to introduce to you my best
friends in the entire world they are the
inner circle looks yet beyond it's
around them seven winners I can do that
the four men that Chris Jericho
hand-picked to watch his back
Santana and Ortiz proud powerful Sammi
Guevara the self-styled Spanish god
[Applause]
and the undefeated powerhouse Jake Hager
they make up the bitter circle this is a
strain so far and it's not your lives
right that guy right there has never
kissed a girl I'd say this is the
greatest night of his life for sure all
right
[Music]
Oh Oh my brother my father figure
Oh first stop shut up
why
first off let me just say thank you they
say
[Applause]
I'm so excited for tonight we got all
these damn gifts for you but I think
there's not gonna be a better gift than
the one I'm about to give you what is it
what is it oh they say a picture's worth
a thousand words put it I think this
one's priceless Oh what is it
how would you look at that
yeah it is thisis all right
that's amazing what a great present
thank you
Spanish God yeah yeah bye boo if by side
what you see y'all alright well right
here we got your little pony quad gift
basket hey hey you almost forgot it's
wintertime and you know what that means
it's flu season and here you go Cris
meet my mom she told me this you put a
little bit on your betcha
and by la cama everything it is good
little more powerful stop it at their
neighborhood bodega real sample daga
boys there
[Applause]
it's puppeteer to the bow
[Applause]
Jericho honorary Nuyorican no no got you
uh Barrett chunk lent us right I'm just
saying these these double as a weapon
I don't know a lot of Spanish moms do
they know what's up oh you know you know
what this is you don't know what this is
little bit of the 40
[Applause]
it's fun tonight oh you just became
unofficial or equal well it's not
honorary anymore oh this is pretty much
the greatest night of my life so far but
somebody's missing to speak as far as
options where is the big hurt Jake Hagar
where is he where's Jake Hagar
[Applause]
pull hold on a second big hurt what is
that
it's for you her name Chris Jericho's I
don't know heard of me
you saying
I mean like I said look at this